[Musique]
les choses se précisent concernant la
reprise de l'école le 11 mai prochain
lors d'une vidéoconférence avec les
maires de france le chef de l'état a
annoncé les mesures qui s'appliquerait
dans toute la france lors de cette
première étape du déconfinement un
retour sur les bancs de l'école
progressif et nationale qui selon
emmanuel macron s'adaptera aux réalités
de chaque territoire
une réouverture des écoles prioritaire
selon le gouvernement pour éviter le
décrochage scolaire particulièrement
inquiétant dans certains endroits du
territoire
la réintégration des élèves se fera par
sections en commençant par la maternelle
et les classes de cp et cm2 pour le
primaire mais si le ministre de
l'éducation indiqué que les élèves ne
devrait pas être plus de 15 par classe
certains parents s'inquiètent tout de
même de cette reprise qu'ils jugent
prématuré pour répondre à ces
inquiétudes
emmanuel macron a expliqué il n'y aura
pas d'obligation du retour à l'école
il faudra de la souplesse une reprise de
l'école sur la base du volontariat donc
une méthode qui peut sembler étonnante
dans un pays où l'école est normalement
obligatoire pour tous jusqu'à 16 ans
alors la reprise de l'école sera sur la
base du volontariat
bonne ou mauvaise idée
alors bonne ou mauvaise idée jean michel
maire ça paraît une bonne idée comme ça
sur le papier mais moi je trouve ça un
véritable scandale
l'état se décharge de ses
responsabilités et du coût des charges
sa responsabilité sur les parents nous
imagine à rester sage et des parents qui
vont devoir décider de même s'ils
envoient leurs enfants à l'école ou pas
et on prend le risque d'être malade
s'est opposé à l'état de dire il ya un
risque il n'y a pas de risques a pas de
risque on envoie les enfants à l'école
s'il arrive qu'on les laisse chez eux
si c'est pas aux parents de décider si
leur enfant risque d'être malade ou pas
je vous c'est une pièce à choix au riz
pour les parents s'adressent les tracks
doit alors gilles verdez la base de la
société française c'est l'école
obligatoire la loi jules ferry 1882 est
là parce que l'état n'est pas capable de
savoir ce qu'il faut faire
et bientôt on coupe en deux cette
histoire de france qui nous unit tous
mais ça veut dire qu'après loria plus
rien d'obligatoire chacun fait ce qu'il
veut
où est la loi où sont les règlements moi
je suis furieux contre sa joue les
figurants le sait vraiment c'est oui
mais ça je suis furax parce que l'epa se
déresponsabilise fait n'importe quoi
qu'est ce qu'on va faire soit tout le
monde y va soit personne il va à l'école
voilà alors valérie benaïm non mais
c'est pas l'école qui est obligatoire
c'est l'éducation c'est l'enseignement
donc on peut le faire à la maison
l'enseignement parce que la fcc sprint
et une chalaisien n'y a pas de bonnes
solutions de façon ya les moins pires
est la moins pire c'est que quand même
ils sortent du nid et autour de l'idée
que chacun peut fait à sa mesure parce
que de toute façon on aurait dit c'est
obligatoire vous devez transmettre aux
enfants vous auriez aller en disant en
force
on nous oblige on est obligé à enlever
nos enfants en danger maintenant vous
dis pas ça
en clair à la carte à partir du moment
où quand même parce que j'ai bien
entendu le message indique à sion il a
dit il faut quand même que vous ayez à
disposition les moyens de faire
l'enseignement à la maison la maman pour
aller en glissant pas non non non en
fait commencé ma vie que ce soit ou tour
rien il faut que ça n'est jamais
contente alors on est complètement est
extrêmement compliqué donc évidemment
confie
mais c'était dans l'après midi aux
alentours de 4 heures emmanuel macron
annoncé au maire par le biais de
l'elysée que l'école se fera sur la base
du volontariat par progressivité et par
concertation regarde
autre information très importante à la
suite de cette réunion les écoles pour
les écoles et bien il n'y aura pas
l'obligation pour les parents d'envoyer
leurs enfants à l'école cela se fera sur
la base du volontariat par progressivité
pas concertation c'est une information
importante que beaucoup de parents
d'élèves se posait depuis maintenant
plusieurs jours
alors ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'avec
cette annonce et que lors de son
audition à l'assemblée mardi nominés de
l'est donc l'éducation jean michel
bancaire avait été clair regarde mais un
élève ne sera jamais en dehors de
l'obligation scolaire tient le dire vous
allez avoir des familles par exemple qui
ne souhaitent pas renvoyer nos enfants
c'est possible mais dans ce cas là il
est effectivement soumis à
l'enseignement à distance mais vous ne
pourrez plus avoir le cas d'un élève qui
n'est nulle pa or malheureusement je les
dis c'est le cas d'environ 4% des élèves
aujourd'hui et dans certains territoires
sont beaucoup plus que 4 % puisque 4%
c'est une moyenne alors il ya de
nombreux parents d'élèves qui était
inquiet par cette rentrée notamment face
aux conditions d'hygiènes parfois mon
compte dans les écoles
regardez c'est le cas d'une mère de
famille qui s'appelle isabelle regarder
ça il est hors de question que nous
fassions rentrer nos enfants avec des
conditions sanitaires qui ne respecte
pas le plan d'urgence votée c'est à dire
respecter les remettre un médecin quand
on sait qu'on peut quand même se poser
la question au niveau des maternelles
comment cela va pouvoir se mettre en
place
ensuite tout ce qui est on voit déjà que
ya pas de savon dans le plus dans la
plupart des écoles que ce soit le
premier degré ou même dans les collèges
et les lycées a de quoi s'essuyer les
mains
il n'y a pas de gel les masques bon la
problématique nationale est ce que est
ce que faire rentrer 12 millions
d'élèves c'est raisonnable est ce qu'on
aura 12 millions de masques
est-ce qu'on va demander aux élèves de
porter des masques que les enseignants
ensuite au niveau des classes il est
inimaginable de faire rentrer des
classes avec des effectifs actuels je
rappelle quand même maternelle premier
degré c'est trente et un élèves
maternelles et primaires
trente et un élèves dans vingt mètres
carrés les conditions ne sont pas
réunies alors jean michel mr
euro-mondial ses 16 où ça arrive un aveu
d'échec total du gouvernement c'est à
dire qu'ils pataugent complètement sur
la connaissance du risque
parce que oui qu'ils savent qu'il ya
aucun risque est à ce point là on
envoyait tous les enfants oui sa
paillasse n'en vois aucun enfant
principe de précaution et quand mme à
lelystad or mais quand tu dis on peut
faire danser les mots à des codes désolé
moi ma fille et la femme baquet chez les
cruise jeu les cochons selon matt ne
peut pas faire le rhône en ciel oui mais
valérie le long ça y est pop et ex porte
parole des républicains là vraiment
votre avis sur il m'intéresse énormément
là dessus écoutez franchement quand on
écoute est madame pinatel qui mère des
enfants
on ne rentrera plus jamais à l'école
est-ce que je suis désolé mais la
réalité c'est pour les virus il sera là
en juin il sera là on ne sait pas en
octobre a donc bien sûr qu'il faut
trouver des solutions
est ce que dit valérie je ne comprends
mais ça c'est dans les familles où tout
va bien mais mettez-vous à la place les
familles où il ya des grosses
difficultés déjà décidées pour ses
propres enfants
éventuellement de les mettre en danger
ou pas c'est déjà une énorme
responsabilité
mais en plus les familles où les parents
sont séparés qui va prendre la décision
ça va être un enfer et enfin les enfants
qui sont déjà très absente d'école dans
des familles où les enfants sont en
échec scolaire et qui nous devrons
partons à l'école ça va être un enfer
aussi la devise républicaine c'est
liberté égalité fraternité égalité c'est
tous les enfants à l'école en même temps
on adapte au départ avec des 2000 classe
oui mais l'obligation scolaire elle est
là et la france se doit de donner un
enseignement à tous les enfants de la
même façon ça veut dire non ça va deux
fois ses parents en les enfants à
l'école
mais quand il arrive quoi il ya un
principe de réalité de toute façon de
laver alors qu'ils retournent à l'école
valérie oui mais non le virus sera là de
la même façon on a compris que les
engagements de toutes façons afin
qu'elles tout cas malheureusement
terrible et bien sûr ne tombent pas
malades
donc évidemment il faut qu'ils
retournent à l'école on ne peut pas
rester dans cette nulle en se disant
parce que j'ai les moyens de faire
l'école à mes enfants donc c'est ok
c'est pas la réalité
il ya plein de ce qu'ils décrochent une
bosse et je le redis j'ai dit avant-hier
puis c'est très important qu il ya plein
d'enfants maltraités et d'être à la
maison c'est un risque sur une petit
plus pour eux le couple est allé à
l'école
rien ne surveiller les bons soins sur
les enfants et le fait qu'ils soient pas
en danger et si vous entendez que ce
soit à plus de 119 sophie koch non mais
moi j'ai trois enfants je vois pas en
quoi entre le 25 mai et le 30 juin
ils vont retourner à l'école pour faire
quoi en règle générale le dernier mois
d'abord il coûte rien d'abord on a eu le
droit de retrait des professeurs là on
leur a dit attention droit de retrait ça
va être compliqué et va pouvoir alors
justifié le droit de retrait ensuite on
nous dit bon on met tous les enfants à
l'école avec effectivement classe par
classe etc
comment est-ce qu'on respecte la
distanciation sociale pendant la
récréation on peut pas y en avait 15 ans
s'offre une classe comme sophie excusé
mais économe à faire pour aller chercher
les enfants à l'école chauffé il faut
bien les points mais ophélie la sortie
des classes
non mais sophie lorain excusez-moi son
fils mais j'aime énormément là mais la
question est claire c'est est ce que
vous comprenez la base du volontariat
bonne ou mauvaise idée
là vous mais pas répondu à la question
moi j'ai reçu un mail de l'école en me
disant ok donc elle volontariat mais les
enfants vont devoir suivre le programme
à la lettre mais comment bah oui en fait
on va recevoir les cours il ya plus de
vidéos zoom ça ne sera plus dispensés
par les professeurs donc nous on va
devoir le faire nous très mauvaise idée
très mauvais dans les jules verne et je
n'arrive pas du tout à comprendre et
j'étais extrêmement choquée mais petit
j'aime beaucoup ta vie valérie benaïm
parce que valérie les enfants ils
peuvent rester à la maison
s'il ya une continuité pédagogique
assuré l'équipe perd sa valérie mais oui
comment il pourra ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
choisir et ce sont des familles aisées
ce sont les familles privilégiées qui
peuvent aider leurs enfants toutes les
familles ou tome où il n'ya pas de
moyens ou y'a pas d'ordinateur ou les
parents ne peuvent pas aider n'y a pas
de continuité donc
non pas le choix les pauvres sont ils
sont obligés d'aller à l'école et les
riches ils ont droit de choisir la
société que vous préconisez je suis très
déçu que ce soit vous c'est une société
inégalitaire balles siffler deux minutes
deux minutes il voulut et valérie voulu
répondre l instant je voudrais qu'on
voit souvenez vous la semaine dernière
il y avait l'enseignant syndicaliste
benjamins à marcq était avec nous pour
évoquer ses craintes par rapport à la
rentrée et règlements à l'été regardez
moi est ce que le gouvernement peut
envisager deux secondes deux secondes de
dire aux enseignants et de dire aux
élèves
vous allez vous retrouver à 35 dans
trente mètres carrés sans masque sans
tests sérologiques qui nous permet de
dire à ce que emmanuel macron a dit on
va tester sur giroud des symptômes mais
enfin on sait que les adolescents sont
très majoritairement des porteurs
asymptomatiques
donc à partir de là on ne sait pas qui
aura été contaminés qui aura eu
effectivement qui aurait développé des
anticorps sol dont il n'y aura aucune
garantie de sécurité sanitaire et on
envoie les enseignants et les élèves au
casse-pipe pourquoi parce qu'il ya le
patronat derrière parce que le medef
insiste pour que l'activité économique
reprenne et bien pour que l'activité
économique reprenne
il faut que les élèves puissent être
gardés dans les écoles dans les collèges
et les lycées
merci scandale et alors vous votez les
chéris l'école sous la halle sur la base
du volontariat
bonne ou mauvaise idée valérie benaïm
vous voulez répondre oui mais tu es
juste at il est ce que tu as entendu
dire que je préconisais ans que je
faisais quoi que ce soit
je dis simplement que de toute façon
toutes les solutions ne sont pas bonnes
il n'y a pas de bonne solution il ya des
moins pire et en l'occurrence moi je
trouve que effectivement dire aux
parents on vous oblige
ben il ya quelque chose d'assez d'assaut
brutale et massive dure assez rude
effectivement je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi il ya des disparités
et il ya des parents qui ont la
possibilité
les enfants à la maison et à
l'enseignement s'était lavé leur lancée
et d'autres pour qui malheureusement
c'est très compliqué mais je te dis pas
que c'est une bonne solution tu dis que
c'est la moins pire parce que on ne
force pas les parents voilà sur jusqu'à
médias il ya bien sûr vous attendez la
vie de benjamin castaldi le forcené qui
va se consoler il a certainement la
solution comme à chaque fois
on l'attend mais juste avant laurence
faille et oui alors je voudrais dire que
franchement c'est honteux que l'état se
reportent sur le choix des parents
imaginez vous décidez que votre enfant
va à l'école et par malheur votre tante
votre manie ou machin est contaminée
derrière vous rendez compte de la
responsabilité vous aurez prises mais
c'est un cauchemar le truc alors que
c'est même peut-être pas votre enfant
qu'il aura contaminés la loi est la même
pour tous et c'est à l'état de prendre
ses responsabilités et valérie bénaïm je
comprends bien ce qu'elle vit mais la
majeure partie des français vont devoir
aller bosser et vont devoir mettre leurs
enfants à l'école et s'il ya des
problèmes on va leur dire vous voyez
vous avez choisi de mettre votre enfant
à l'école - ils n'ont pas choisi
simplement étroits qu'ils aillent bosser
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le croire quand
même entreprise qui vont devoir leur ya
plein de gens qui vont devoir aller
bosser
donc autant fixer une règle
malheureusement c'est compliqué on a
tous un peu peur mais il ya un moment il
faut avancer tous ensemble parce que
sinon il va jamais s'en sortir alors le
calendrier aujourd'hui plus envisagée
pour le retour en classe et celui ci
lundi 11 mai comme je voulais dit pré
rentrée des professeurs c'est à dire
l'idée de voir voilà comment ça se passe
tranquillement
mardi 12 mai rentrée des élèves de
grande section de maternelle cp cm2
lundi 18 mai rentrée des élèves de 6e
troisième terminal et des lycées
professionnels spécialisés spécialités
industrielles et lundi 25 mai rentrée de
toutes les classes
voilà donc c'est ce qui est préconisé
jean michel je sais que tu voulais
rebondir avant d'avoir la vibration du
forcené est la solution de force et qui
va nous rejoindre
mary jean michel toulet rebondir est
sous la neige une fiche de 36 à brac
entièrement d'accord avec lens et c'est
vrai que pour une fois l'école s'arrête
souvent me joins au début juin à cause
du bac et c'est donc avec démontré pour
dijon autant de risques pour les tiges
ou non la vraie sarah crash n'a tué
safar est le cas banon le bal des écoles
c'est là des écoles publiques ses amis
je vois pas du tout
jean michel maire j'ai des enfants ils
arrêtent le trop loin j'ai jamais vu
mais entre en vacances le 10 juin
je pense que vous êtes je sais pas vous
avez vu ça mais à mon avis vous êtes
vous n'habitez pas certainement pas en
france
les indices us dit oui gilles ouais je
voudrais rendre hommage aux profs claqué
sur la continuité qui volent super bien
qu'il prépare pour les enfants et deux à
tout le personnel qui va nettoyer
désinfecter les écoles ou les gens qui
vont se mobiliser pour nos enfants
vraiment ils sont remarquables il
commence déjà et franchement bravo et
merci à eux
moi je moi je voudrais faire aussi un
gros big up aux parents qui sont
confinés chez eux et qu'ils se tapent du
travail de fou c'est à dire que quand
vous avez deux ou trois enfants ou
quatre enfants alors là c'est une
catastrophe ça veut dire que ça vous
prend de 8 heures du matin jusqu'à
minuit mardi à biarritz en rigoler et il
faut savoir que maintenant même en ce1
ils te demandent des trucs à
l'impression d'être un simple nous faut
encore mais moi moi on sait loin déjà je
suis largué largué d'arqués oui oui
c'est une catastrophe
on va voir ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs tiens de cette mesure
la base du volontariat est ce que vous
êtes pour est ce que vous êtes contre 1
regardons bonne idée 44% mauvaise idée
56%
voyez c'est pas je pensais je pensais
que sa lettre salle est plus loyal avoir
plus de pourcentage pour la mauvaise
idée mais il ya que 56% donc à 44% des
français qui ne compte que c'est une
bonne idée
le volontariat